THE STATE OF DAILYMOTION:
Remember Dailymotion? 10 to 15 years ago,
Dailymotion was one of the leading video sharing
platforms in the world after YouTube of course.
They were often much slower than YouTube at
taking down copyrighted content. They also had
looser rules regarding when a frequent copyright
infringer would actually be taken off the platform
which made them a honeypot for cartoons, TV shows,
and movies. In fact, just a couple of years ago,
Dailymotion was fined €5.5 million for precisely
this and that was just one of several occasions.
But with the rise of affordable streaming services
like Netflix and Disney+ and the utter domination
of YouTube, Dailymotion has largely fallen into
the shadows or atleast that’s what you would
think. It turns out that Dailymotion is still
quite popular amongst a demographic outside of
western countries. In November of 2023, for
example, much of their web traffic came from
India, Indonesia, Egypt, and Vietnam which added
up to a total of Dailymotion enjoyed 582 million
visitors. To be fair, YouTube enjoyed 117 billion
visitors, so Dailymotion obviously does not even
come close to YouTube pulling in just 0.5%
of the traffic. With that being said though,
Dailymotion is still very much a giant in its own
right, but that’s pretty much the only thing that
Dailymotion still has going for themselves
at this point. In mid 2015, a French media
holding company called Vivendi bought out the vast
majority of Dailymotion for just $241 million. For
perspective, Google bought YouTube for over 5
times that price nearly 10 years earlier. And
it’s not like Dailymotion was late to the video
streaming game either. They were actually founded
way back in March of 2005 just 30 days after
YouTube. But, Dailymotion never enjoyed that same
growth or success of YouTube or even Vimeo who at
one point IPO’d at an $8.5 billion. Since then,
Vimeo’s valuation has fallen 93% but they’re still
worth over twice as much as what Dailymotion was
acquired for. So, here’s the tragic story of one
of the OG video streaming platforms: Dailymotion.
HUMBLE BEGINNINGS:
Taking a look back,
the story of Dailymotion dates back to a french
man named Benjamin Bejbaum. Ben was born on
November 20, 1976 in Paris, France to a family
of doctors. Despite his academic lineage though,
Ben was never the biggest fan of school. In
fact, he would quickly develop a reputation
of being that one lazy kid that skipped school too
much and got suspended. But, despite his antics,
he did manage to get pretty good grades and would
eventually graduate with honors with a degree in
mathematics and information sciences. He didn’t
really have much interest in pursuing mathematics
as a career path though. In fact, throughout his
college years, he had actually picked up a habit
of late night gaming which quickly turned into Ben
teaching himself how to code and creating his own
websites and games. But, while he enjoyed pursuing
these projects, they didn’t exactly pay the bills,
so he would end up picking up a bunch of
odd jobs throughout the 90s to get by. This
included helping tourists, being a telemarketer,
and working in the telecom industry. Feeling lost,
Ben would eventually return to college when he
was approached by a cafe manager. The manager
was looking to put together a website for his cafe
and felt that Ben was the perfect guy to do it and
that’s when everything clicked for Ben. What he
needed to do was create a web design studio and
help local businesses create their own websites.
He would team up with one of his cousins, and
together, they would create Iguana Studio in 2000.
Over the next couple of years, Iguana Studio would
evolve into a decent personal business allowing
Ben to take a vacation to New York in 2005,
and it was here that the idea for Dailymotion was
born. You see, Ben had taken some videos of the
snowfall in Manhattan and wanted to share it with
his friends and family back in Paris. But to his
surprise, there was no easy way to share large
video files over the internet. So, as soon as
he returned home, he would team up with one of his
friends, Olivier Poitrey and whip up a simple site
to share videos online called short.tv. Initially,
this was much more of a public service as opposed
to a serious business but to the duo’s surprise,
the website would quickly pick up quite a bit of
momentum within France. Short.tv was very much
just something that these to were running out
of Poitrey’s apartment. So, to accommodate for
this influx in traffic, they would raise a modest
€6,000 from 6 people, and they would rename the
website Dailymotion. Dailymotion never experienced
the scale of growth that YouTube enjoyed but they
were growing pretty fast within France. In fact,
just 18 months after being founded,
Dailymotion would lock in the largest
French Web 2.0 fundraising round of 2006 worth
7 million euros. Just a few months after this,
Google would buy YouTube for $1.65 billion which
pushed Dailymotion’s investors to double down on
their bet. In 2007, they would provide Dailymotion
with another 25 million euros in funding to try
their hand at global expansion. But while they had
access to a large amount of capital, the reality
is that no amount of money is every enough in
the world of free online video streaming. And
the Dailymotion team would learn this first
hand as they faced challenge after challenge.
OBSTACLE AFTER OBSTACLE:
With little to no content moderation,
Dailymotion would almost immediately be dragged
into the world of copyright litigation. In fact,
just two years after founding the company,
Dailymotion would get bogged down with their
first copyright infringement lawsuit. They tried
to argue that they were just a content platform,
not an active infringer of copyright regulation,
but this argument didn’t hold up in court. The
court ruled that Dailymotion was very much aware
of copyrighted content being uploaded onto their
website, and as such, it was up to them to
remove it in a timely manner. Not exactly the
ruling they were looking for but it’s not like
they had the time to appeal. Every single day,
Dailymotion was burning boatloads of money keeping
the website up and running for millions of people
to use for free. So, their number one priority was
to get monetization up and running so that they
could atleast off set some of the losses. However,
this was a lot easier said than done. You see,
in the late 2000s, instream video ads like the
one you probably saw before this video weren’t
even a thing. All you had were the static display
ads that you saw on websites. Advertisers were
also rather skeptical about digital advertising in
general. So, Dailymotion was stuck showing display
ads on a video platform which as you would
guess was not all that lucrative. As such,
Dailymotion was quickly back to the fundraising
table in 2009. The good news though was that they
were able to get some pretty reputable backers
such as the French government themselves who
invested 17 million into the platform. Just as
Dailymotion was getting back on their feet though,
they would be hit with not just another
lawsuit but an outright ban from India in
May of 2012. Fortunately, India would roll back
this ruling in the following months citing that
only certain URLs should be blocked for copyright
infringement, not entire websites. This event made
Dailymotion realize that they not only needed
allies within France but around the world. So,
they would form partnerships with several
international media publications including Hearst
Media and Bloomberg. They would also open offices
in London, San Francisco, and Singapore. This may
have given them a better reputation but it didn’t
exactly stop the lawsuits. In fact, their home
city would fine them for 1.3 million euros in late
2014. This was followed by another temporary ban
in India and a permanent ban in Russia. Throughout
this entire time period, Dailymotion was basically
just juggling 3 things over and over again. They
were addressing copyright infringement lawsuits,
trying to raise money, and then solving issues
with scale. After that, they would once again
address copyright infringement lawsuits, raise
capital, and solve issues with scale. This vicious
cycle repeated over and over again up until
2017. By this point, streaming services were
really taking off so most copyright holders
turned their focus to monetizing streaming
services instead of going after Dailymotion. But,
while this finally gave Dailymotion a break, this
was also accompanied by a large outflow of users
which brings us into the modern day Dailymotion.
THE TRAGIC FATE:
Honestly, I don’t think
Dailymotion ever really wanted to be some sort
of piracy streaming center. Other sites like
Megaupload very much leaned into this persona
and used it their benefit to maximize profits.
Dailymotion on the other hand was just truly just
trying to create a competitor to YouTube but it
just so happened that piracy is what it’s users
often turned to Dailymotion for. Much of this just
had to do with the immense resources that YouTube
had thanks to Google. They had the advertisers,
the ability to stomach insane losses, the
Google ecosystem, massive infrastructure,
and the ability to payout creators. As such,
YouTube was the clear choice for regular videos,
and Dailymotion naturally become a place that
hosted content that was not available on YouTube
which mainly consistent of copyrighted content.
This put Dailymotion in a really tricky situation.
Do they turn a blind eye to copyrighted content to
pump up their user base or do they continue with
their nobel efforts. It seems that Dailymotion
was stuck in a constant limbo between these two
efforts as they fought one lawsuit after another.
Eventually, a decision was forced upon them when
streaming took off. With affordable streaming
services, most people simply had no reason to
use an off brand version of YouTube anymore. As
such, the interest in Dailymotion slowly bled
out throughout the second half of the 2010s.
It seems that the founders somewhat expected
this as they very much made decisions that would
protect themselves from this outcome. In fact,
Ben was already taking steps out the door by mid
2008 when he stepped down from being CEO. And he
would completely cash out of the company
at roughly a 120 million euro valuation
in the early 2010s. It’s not clear how much
of the company he still owned at this point,
but if it was any sizable amount, he likely walked
away with tens of millions. Since then, it seems
that Ben has circled all the way back to academics
as he is now a professor of Python at the Albert
School in Paris. As for Olivier, he stuck around
at Dailymotion till mid 2016 as CTO. After that,
Olivier would score a job at Netflix as
director of engineer. And if you didn’t know,
Netflix pays $1.2 million cash for directors
of software engineering. So, I think it’s safe
to say that the founders are fortunately doing
better than ever. The same, however, cannot be
said about Dailymotion. Over the years, there were
some brief moments of great hope for the company.
For example, in 2014, Microsoft nearly invested
in Dailymotion, something that may have taken
the platform to a wholenother level. But, this
deal unfortunately never came to fruition. What
did end up happening was Vivendi buying out
Dailymotion for roughly $300 million. Since then,
Dailymotion has really just been running on
fumes. The main reason that they’re still
somewhat popular today is largely just because
they used to be popular. And with Dailymotion
making decisions like removing the comment
section and even the view counter altogether,
largely because their videos weren’t getting any
views, things don’t look so bright for Dailymotion
moving forward. Best case scenario, it
seems that Dailymotion will just be be
tossed around from one owner to another
just like AOL or Yahoo while it still has
some juice left. Eventually though, that juice
will run out at which point the platform will
be completely shutdown and that is the
tragic fate of Dailymotion. Another OG
video platform that’s facing a similar fate
is Vimeo. Check out this video to learn more.